[Música]
el primer instinto que tenemos con la
conocemos a una persona siempre es
etiquetar la y la primera etiqueta que
siempre ponemos a alguien es hombre o
mujer
es es un mecanismo que hemos vuelto
automático automático y subconsciente
todas las personas de la sociedad
es algo incluso que hacemos antes de
conocer a las personas cuando mi madre
está embarazada de mí la pregunta que
recibió más a menudo fue que vas a tener
niña o niño no hemos ni nacido aún y la
sociedad ya quiere saber que vamos a
hacer muchas veces esto es para saber
qué le vamos a comprar a la o el bebé
una vez que nazca
podía azul y el autito para el niño y el
poder rosado y la muñequita para la niña
esta necesidad de conocer el género es
algo que nos sigue en la vida entonces
una vez que haya nacido al lado del bebé
seguimos con las mismas preguntas esta
vez para saber si le decimos que fuerte
ese niñito qué fuerte se ve si es niño y
qué hermosa princesita si es niña
y este comportamiento es algo que
seguimos a lo largo de nuestra vida
porque es un comportamiento que
replicamos con todas las personas que
conocemos
sin embargo somos más de 7000 millones
de personas en la tierra y equivale mos
a mucho más que dos simples casillas de
hombre y mujer lo que pasa lo que pasa
es que conocemos se nos asigna un género
en base a nuestro sexo y estas dos
palabras suelen ser usadas de manera
intercambiable pero en realidad son muy
diferentes
en primer lugar tenemos el sexo que
equivale a las características
biológicas y a la anatomía de nuestro
sistema reproductivo es decir los
genitales los cromosomas el perfil
hormonal etcétera y por otro lado
tenemos el género que equivale a las
características sociales culturales
psicológicas y de comportamiento de una
persona es decir que es algo que vamos
creando en base a nuestras vivencias y
eso a su vez crear una identidad propia
a cada persona
la identidad de género se refiere a cómo
nos auto percibimos como personas por
ejemplo una persona se percibe como
mujer mientras que la orientación sexual
se refiere a la atracción que sentimos
hacia las otras personas
esta charla no va a hablar de
orientación sexual sino que de género de
expresiones de género es decir cómo nos
expresamos a través de nuestros
comportamientos manerismos nuestras
modificaciones corporales forma de
vestir de hablar etcétera
entonces si retomamos la frase se nos
asigna un género en base a nuestro sexo
eso significa que la sociedad nos dicta
que si nacemos con un pene el sexo
masculino nuestro género necesariamente
tiene que ser el masculino acompañado de
todos los roles que eso conlleva y por
otro lado nos dicta que si nacemos con
vagina el sexo femenino nuestro género
necesariamente tiene que ser el género
femenino acompañado de todos los roles
que eso conlleva
pero la realidad es otra y el asunto no
está en blanco y negro porque nuestro
género y nuestra expresión de género no
necesariamente tienen que ir alineados
con las expectativas que conllevan que
conllevan nuestro sexo me explico
seguramente a muchas personas aquí les
ha pasado cruzarse con una persona que
presenta características masculinas y
femeninas y que han hecho seguramente
han empezado a ver a la persona de
arriba para abajo tratando de determinar
qué género es y seguramente han ido
pasando por un checklist mental tratando
de determinar eso que seguramente ha ido
algo así tiene barba no tiene manzana de
adán lo veo como su voz baja qué tipo de
ropa lleva ancha tiene pecho sí y mucho
como que tiene muchos y todo lo demás
indica que supuestamente estos de nombre
entonces empiezan a confundir porque ven
características tanto masculinas y
femeninas en una persona y no saben qué
hacer
yo sé lo que se siente ser esa persona
analizada porque durante mucho tiempo lo
he vivido porque porque yo nací del sexo
femenino
y durante mucho tiempo yo tenía una
apariencia bastante andrógena o ambigua
que significaba que la gente no sabía si
tratarme como un hombre o como una mujer
entonces qué hacía la gente justamente
me miraba de mis pies a mi cabeza
tratando de determinarlo con su propio
checklist mental lo chistoso es que la
gente cree que es súper discreta conoces
pero les garantizo que no lo son para
nada
de ellos sentimos cada milímetro que
recorre su mirada y déjenme decirles que
cuando alguien te mira de arriba para
abajo y no porque te está chequeando
vuelve la situación super incómoda
si no tuviéramos esa necesidad de poner
una etiqueta de género a todas las
personas
habríamos un espacio que fomenta un
trato igualitario entre todas las
personas
porque no podemos negar que las personas
se comportan de manera diferente según
el género de la persona con quién se
encuentra una persona no se comporta de
la misma manera si tiene enfrente de
ella lo que percibe como un hombre o lo
que percibe como una mujer
habiendo nacido mujer y teniendo la
apariencia que tengo ahora que se
considera más masculina he tenido la
suerte y la desgracia de vivir ese
cambio de trato en carne propia
la gente me trata de manera muy
diferente ahora haciendo lo que se
percibe lo que perciben como un hombre
que con no percibían a una mujer
ejemplos típicos ahora me dicen que
tengo que ser fuerte y sal proteger a
las mujeres cuando antes yo tenía que
hacer la persona protegida
entrando a más detalles usemos el
ejemplo de la protección de los bichos
es muy típico no
yo les garantizo que si a mí me
encuentran en una sala con una abeja la
van a encontrar a la abeja feliz volando
por la sala y a mí me van a encontrar
escondiéndome debajo de una mesa una
cama una lámpara lo que sea que yo
encuentre haya o no una mujer u otra
persona en la sala
eso no tiene nada que ver con un
comportamiento de género tiene que ver
con que yo les tengo un miedo tremendo a
esos bichos malvados
y al final todos tenemos miedos
e
otro ejemplo es que ahora algunos
hombres se toman la libertad de hacer
bromas machistas
porque porque me consideran ahora parte
de la manada de los hombres eso esas
bromas que jamás hubieran pensado en
hacerme si hubieran conocido si no
hubieran percibido percibido como mujer
esos ejemplos son una realidad que me
parece que tenemos el poder de cambiar
podemos dejar de actuar de manera
diferente según el género de la persona
con quien nos encontramos
cuando yo les digo que nací de sexo
femenino es decir que cuando llegue a
este mundo el médico me vio y a los
pocos segundos anunció
y esa declaración determinó de manera
instantánea qué tipo de persona yo iba a
tener que ser es decir qué roles tenían
asociados al hecho de haber nacido con
un sexo femenino
porque en nuestros entornos de
aprendizaje nos enseñan justamente esos
roles y estereotipos que por un lado los
hombres tienen que tener pene barba
tienen que ser agresivos empoderados y
pobre de ellos de que se pongan a jugar
con una muñeca y por otro lado nos
enseñan que una mujer nace con vagina
pecho tiene que ser delicada y sumisa y
pobre de ella de que se se suba a un
árbol y se ensucie
mientras yo iba creciendo yo no cumplía
con esos roles y estereotipos
simplemente porque no me nacían y me
parecían absurdos al inicio no fue
problemático hasta que yo llegué a
cierta edad en la cual no se consideraba
ya aceptable de que yo actuara de manera
diferente entonces empecé a tratar de
encajar en esos roles y estereotipos
femeninos que se esperaban de mí por
ejemplo a mí me encantaba andar en
patineta la patineta era mi modo de
transporte a todo lado
y cada día le iba agarrando más y más
confianza y me iba en cantando más me
iba a la pista de patineta hacia los
trucos o saltos con todos los otros
chicos que estaban ahí
y en el invierno hacía lo mismo con el
snowboard en la nieve
y llegó el día en el que los chicos de
la pista de patineta me empezaron a
molestar porque yo era la única chica
ahí
y fue tan fuerte el rechazo social que
eso fue el fin de mis días de patineta
hasta hoy día me da rabia de que me
hayan tratado de así pero me da más
rabia en realidad que yo no haya tenido
el coraje de seguir con esa pasión tan
arraigada que tenía me da rabia porque
tengo la certeza que hoy en día hubiera
podido incluso de estar compitiendo
haciendo saltos y trucos
pero justamente por esa presión social
tan fuerte decidí que ya era tiempo de
ser tan diferente y de una vez encajar
en lo que la sociedad esperaba de mí yo
seguía recibiendo de esos comentarios
hasta hace un año
hasta hace un año me seguían afectando
pero esta vez con la apariencia que
tengo ahora eran los mismos comentarios
pero al revés es decir ahora me decían
tienes que comportarte como un hombre de
verdad
pero bueno como verán mi forma de
expresarme no es más que linda entonces
al final los conceptos de hombre y mujer
nos limitan en nuestro día a día porque
nos obligan a encajar en un binarismo de
género en el cual todas las personas no
necesariamente encaja el punto es que la
sociedad se basa en nuestra apariencia
para determinar nuestro género tal como
lo hizo mi médico y eso no toma en
consideración nuestras vivencias y
nuestros propios intereses nuestros
cuerpos y nuestra forma de ser no
necesariamente tienen que encajar con
los roles y estereotipos de género por
ejemplo una mujer si se siente mujer sin
pecho puede perfectamente ser una mujer
tal vez se quitó los pechos porque tuve
una enfermedad o tal vez si quito los
pechos porque simplemente no quería
tener pecho
el hecho de tener pecho o no no la hace
ni menos ni más mujer u hombre
existen también mujeres con barba
y les habló de una barba completa de los
bigotitos que de los cuales nos ponemos
un poco paranoicos a algunos y algunas
por ejemplo está de harman cauda hammam
que aún es en la mujer británica que
vivió toda su infancia y su adolescencia
escondiendo su cara y rasurando pse por
el miedo al bullying que recibía en el
colegio
ella ahora adulta es súper orgullosa de
su barba como lo pueden ver y nunca se
ha sentido tan femenina porque porque
dejó de asociar el hecho de tener una
barba algo estrictamente masculina
al final tener una barba es ser humano
por otro lado tenemos usemos un ejemplo
de los hombres se les considera menos
hombres a los que serán sentidos entre
ellos
qué guapo te ves hoy día esa camisa
hacer resaltar tus ojos y la respuesta
típica sería no gracias hermano pero no
yo yo no voy por ahí
de qué están hablando si están
recibiendo un cumplido
es una pena que se asocia el acto de dar
cumplidos algo estrictamente femenino
con raya es un ser humano dando un
cumplido a otro ser humano y la idea de
los cumplidos es que nos hagan sentir
bien el género en la expresión de género
no es tan binaria es decir no existen
dos opciones sino que es un espectro
existe una multitud de opciones de
identificarse y de expresarse que van
más allá de los roles y los estereotipos
de género
deberíamos ser libres de adecuar
nuestros cuerpos nuestros manierismos
según lo que nos haga sentir mejor en
nuestra propia piel y de esa manera
logramos vivir bajo una autenticidad
óptima el problema es que con los años
hemos ido creando construcciones
sociales que nos obligan a encajar en
dos casillas digo que han sido creadas
con los años porque
son cuestiones que cambian de época en
época de cultura en cultura por ejemplo
en los tiempos antiguos
los hombres se ponían vestidos o sin ir
más allá hoy en día el traje típico de
los hombres es una falda presento a mi
padrastro que es escocés mientras que si
un hombre caminara por este lado del
mundo con una falda recibiría muchísimo
odio y en ese sentido los roles y los
estereotipos de género son una son
culturales y no una verdad universal
entonces al final que significa
realmente ser hombre o ser mujer es algo
que nos trae un beneficio como sociedad
dividida a todas las personas de esta
manera tan simplista y binaria yo creo
que viviríamos en una sociedad menos
discriminadora que seríamos personas
mucho más felices y esperamos
más respetuosas
y menos prejuiciosos
somos responsables de nuestra propia
concientización y les invito a que tomen
un tiempo para reflexionar para buscar
en internet más información sobre cómo
nos podemos identificar y expresar
justamente que para que podamos abrir un
mundo que nos y que no busque limitar a
las personas sino que busquen abrir las
puertas a una diversidad enriquecedora
yo soy crisis personalmente a pesar de
tener una apariencia física
supuestamente más masculina no me
identifico ni como hombre y como mujer y
mi manera de expresarme es bastante
fluida seguramente estarán dado cuenta
algunas personas me dicen que tengo
rasgos femeninos y otros rasgos
masculinos y yo justamente gozó de estas
lides porque no me hace sentir ni
atrapada ni atrapado en roles y en ese
sentido yo personalmente uso pronombres
tanto masculinos como femeninos me da
igual mientras sea con el debido respeto
que deberíamos tratarnos todas las
personas
[Aplausos]